espace frontière de l'infini vers
laquelle voyage notre vaisseau spatial
sa mission de trois ans explorer de
nouveaux mondes étranges découvrir de
nouvelles
attends attends c'est quoi ça si la
planète celle où là c'était quoi
retourne pas
[Musique]
mais une mission de trois ans un peu
plus même
mais on va revenir là dessus en détails
après je vous l'avais promis aujourd'hui
on fait le bilan et on tire les
conséquences de cette belle aventure qui
a été le détatouage au laser alors j'ai
déjà répondu à pas mal des questions
vous m'avez posé un genre pourquoi je
fais ça machin etc
j'ai en effet une faq je vous remets le
lien dans la description mais
aujourd'hui on va faire le bilan et on a
commencé par la fin je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez
après ma dernière séance juste avant le
confinement je vous avais dit que le
médecin m'avait fait une prescription
mais conseillé d'exposer la zone au
soleil pendant l'été et de revenir le
voir à la rentrée et comme je suis
impatient extrêmement observant ben j'ai
fait comme il a dit je suis revenu me
voir à la rentrée et j'ai bronzé connu
cet été
ok alors je me coupe la parole une
minute pour tirer le premier
enseignement de cette grande aventure de
ce rendez vous en terre inconnue en vous
montrant cette photo j'ai bien
conscience que je prends un risque parce
que c'est le genre de truc qui m'a déjà
valu pas mal de démonétisation ou de
limitation d'âge pour méditer pendant
cette série de vidéos des fois parce
qu'on voyait mes fesses des fois on
voyait même pas mes fesses on ya juste
le tatouage avec un petit peu de peau
autour mais youtube estimait qu'on
savait que c'était la peau de mes fesses
donc bim et une fois ça a même été juste
pour une affiche pour le remodeling des
faits ce qui était sur le mur de la
cabine de laser c'était pas ça le plus
épique de l'histoire donc je suis
retourné voir le médecin et il m'a
annoncé la grande nouvelle c'est fini je
ne vous cache pas que ça m'a fait
quelque chose ça fait comme une espèce
de bouffe et de mélancolie
même pas une dernière séance pour la
route rien dans le médecin ils étaient
formels le laser a fait son job il ya
plus rien à en tirer c'est fini on plie
les gaules
voilà ça s'est fini comme çà ferait plus
de 3
après plus de trois ans pour parler un
petit peu de dates faut se rappeler que
cette histoire ça a commencé en décembre
2016 le 2 décembre 2016
exactement puisque c'est la date à
laquelle julien et hammam ont fait le
fameux tatouage j'en profite pour les
saluer d'ailleurs parce qu ils sont
hyper sympa et je vous remets le lien
dans leur compte instagram dans la
description de la vidéo parce qu'ils
font pas que des têtes d'animaux
évidemment ils font plein de trucs super
le détatouage ça a commencé en février
2010 est dans le premier centre avec un
laser qu switched j'ai fait cette séance
là bas avant de décider de changer de
technique parce que je trouvais que ce à
travers un petit peu donc en juin 2018
je passe au laser pico jours et 14
nouvelles séances plus tard et quelques
jours à me faire griller la couronne au
soleil nous voilà en septembre 2020 donc
entre le rendez-vous tatouage est le
dernier rendez-vous chez le médecin il
s'est écoulé exactement trois ans et
neuf mois 3 ans et 9 mois vous rendez
compte de tout ce qu'on peut faire
pendant ce temps là normalement vous
vous en rendez compte parce qu'on en a
parlé dans la dernière vidéo
et si on compte le temps qui s'est
écoulé entre la première séance de laser
et la dernière qu'a eu lieu la en mars
juste avant le confinement et bah ça
fait trois ans et un mois donc de toutes
façons plus de trois ans bon et
puisqu'on en est à parler chiffres et à
faire des calculs on va passer à
l'addition la douloureuse et donc j'ai
fait cette séance de kew switched à 150
euros la séance
plus 14 séances de pick au chaud à 300
et ça nous fait
5 250 euros ouais cinq minutes 250 euros
s'applique un peu quand même mais alors
du coup est-ce que ça a marché
pour ce prix là eh ben je vous propose
de voir ça
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc la bonne nouvelle c'est que
oui ça a marché
c'est nickel même si comme vous pouvez
le constater sur ces images il reste
trois types de petits inconvénients une
espèce de cicatrices à cause de
l'éguille quand je me suis fait tatouer
une zone un petit peu plus clair qu'on
appelle de la dépigmentation qui est lié
au laser et une zone un petit peu plus
sombre on appelle là pour le coup de
l'hyper pigmentation et qui est lié
aussi au laser mais à priori le médecin
m'a dit que tout ça allait s'estomper
avec le temps et en tous cas il ya plus
d'encre bon mais est donc concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on retient de toute cette
aventure bat déjà le laser ça fait mal
alors une séance c'est moins long que la
séance de tatouage original mais ça fait
beaucoup plus mal donc demandé une
ordonnance pour de la pommade
anesthésiante ça marche hyper bien alors
il ya des centres qui font aussi d
injection d'anesthésiant ça je vous
laisse je vous laisse voir c'est à vous
de choisir
mais en tout cas demandé une anesthésie
souffrir pour rien il n'y a absolument
aucune gloire à tirer de ça ensuite se
faire retirer un tatouage ça peut être
long en ce qui me concerne ça a pris
trois ans ça reste un cas individuel et
les deux médecins que j'ai vu mon heat
d'habitude ça allait beaucoup plus vite
mais quand même la preuve c'est que ça
peut prendre trois ans et encore le mien
c'était juste des traces et il n'y avait
pas dont il n'y avait pas de remplissage
et il était tout noir
normalement c'est rapidement qui est
facile à faire partir un autre truc
au début le médecin va vous donner une
estimation du nombre de séances
nécessaire pour faire partir votre
tatouage
alors c'est juste une estimation
soyez bien conscient de ça moi le
premier médecin il m'avait annoncé six
séances
et au final il en a fallu vingt-et-une
donc peut-être prévoyez un petit peu
large au niveau du budget et ça me
permet d'enchaîner sur un autre
enseignement se faire détatouer ça coûte
cher
on a vu en ce qui me concerne cinq mille
250 euros je crois qu'on peut dire que
ça coûte la peau du cul et encore sans
compter le prix du tatouage
donc je vais pas faire le donneur de
leçons en mode mais réfléchissez bien
avant de vous faire tatouer quand même
c'est pas d'idées mais au moins
maintenant vous avez quelques éléments
sur la façon dont ça peut se passer
un détatouage on va dire ça peut se
passer parce que encore une fois mon
canap à valeur universelle à vous
d'intégrer ces éléments dans votre
réflexion et de prendre la décision qui
nous semblera la meilleure pour vous ça
simplement voilà détester c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]